yeah that seems to be a popular
conversation piece especially for
entrepreneurs like i know aubrey marcus
has been quite public about having an
open marriage and
the stuff tied around that but then he
recently did an interview with brian
rose on the
london rule reel where he was talking
about i just couldn't
live with knowing some other guy was
i mean i'm going to water this down but
basically gorilla banging the crap out
of my wife
while i'm out on a trip or something
like that so he switched to
monogamy so why do you think that like
um
why do you think that idea of um open
relationships is so popular with
entrepreneurs i mean like
i mean entrepreneurs like to hack
everything you know we like to
bio hack this and hack relationships you
know sort of thing
what's your thought on that so i think
some of it is because we're becoming
more open with
discussing sexuality that we're actually
talking about
different forms of sexuality or
different kinks or different
relationships again more than we used to
because we have social media as being
shared again even more
so we're being exposed to what we never
got exposed to because we had to go to
the library to buy a book on something
we didn't even know about it we
certainly didn't talk about it over beer
and the mass media wasn't reporting so
social media has given rise to
things like different types of
relationships different kinks different
um forms of partnerships etc
as it's given rise to the the popularity
of psychedelics i mean
15 years ago no entrepreneur was going
to talk to another entrepreneur about
doing drugs unless we tripped over the
issue
and now it's like [ __ ] yeah i'll go to
burning man and do dmt with you or i'll
go to peru and do
you know ayahuasca or i'll go and do
mushrooms in the forehead like
it's becoming a very normal thing so i
think i think some of it is that
um i know aubrey we've shared the stage
together we've talked i've talked spoken
with his his ex now his ex-wife about it
i've spoken to so many different
individuals over the years about open
relationships polyamorous relationships
polygamous relationships
that i'm more intrigued by it but i'm
also very similar to aubrey
i've talked to neil strauss who wrote
the game and the truth and
you know neil went and played in every
single possible realm only to come back
to his girlfriend get married have a kid
and then now he's divorced
i think what he's pointing to is
relationships are tough
um sexuality is tough and confusing and
exciting
um communication is tough and and
so i i'm playing with it to just
understand as well like i have these
human needs
where i want to be able to have other
partners but then i want to be able to
have a trusting
good relationship with my partner and
she'll say well yeah go play with an
escorter yeah go go to a massage place
or go get another
you know have sex with some girl that
you needed a conference but then i'm
kind of going like does she really mean
that
and then then i feel worried that i
should do it and then it's like well do
i really want then i'm like do i really
want to do that or do what
like what do i prefer so i think it's
just dancing around
those discussions that maybe we've had
in our heads or lied about over the
years that now we're more prepared to
to explore a lot of the stuff that
women tell guys to do around
relationships
um boil down to competency tests also
known as [ __ ] testing you
yeah to see if you'll actually do it i
mean there might be some
some truth behind it i mean another
truth that the red pill really brings
when you start to see it is that women
would prefer to share a high value alpha
rather than to be strapped down with a
with a faithful loser i heard you say
that that actually that actually
resonated as accurate to me yeah yeah i
mean as long as you
you are seen in her eyes as her best
option
um i mean she's not going to be fond of
it but she'll tolerate it
well i think we're so i think where my
girlfriend is right now is that
she is probably very okay with if i was
at a conference
if i was at an event and i happened to
meet somebody the energy was there and
we ended up having sex
great do it just don't tell me i think
that's kind of the room she wants to be
in
where i want to be though is more i
don't actually want to lie to her
i would i would actually rather have
like if she says where were you for the
last four hours
not to go i was sitting with guys in the
bar and make up some stupid story
so then it's like well is it worth it is
it worth it to not tell her the truth
because she doesn't really want to know
the truth and i really don't think she's
testing on that one i think it's more it
is just more
as when i'm thinking look she's going to
go travel around the world for three
years
even though she doesn't have the same
level of sexual need that i have
mine's super high um i think
[ __ ] she might meet somebody and end up
wanting to have sex like well she had
sex with people before me is it gonna
really kill me
now i wouldn't want her to have a
partner in addition to me forever
so that's kind of where we are with our
thinking of it is where aubry and his
wife
had like girlfriends and boyfriends like
they they had
partners that they would see every
tuesday and thursday for a year
that's not what i want my relationship i
i really want to have a primary partner
who i get to hang with and color with
and make dinners with and have sex with
but then if that energy strikes itself
as right i'd rather be able to tell the
truth than to lie
see the the the truth about those
conversations
it really boils down to the societal
conditioning that we get hammered into
ourselves our entire lives
through the female primary social worker
and the truth is women don't
see women want truth but they but they
don't want full disclosure
right there's there's almost this
hamster that
loves to be caffeinated in her head you
know running on the wheel like she has
to have some competition anxiety for you
because if she feels like other women
don't desire you and other men don't
want to be like you
then your value starts to go down like
we talk about this process of
betatization through a thousand
concessions which most guys go through
in a marriage at some point
because it just ends up being yes honey
yes yes yes they just stamp everything
yes yes yes yes yes and at some point
she's like
screw this guy you know and it's like
you know they have a conversation about
i love you but i'm not in love with you
and i'm going to take the kids and go to
my mom's house sort of thing and it kind
of spirals from there but
yeah there's a lot of unknowns that kind
of sit in a lot of guys blind spots that
i just find fascinating especially from
the perspective of
being an entrepreneur and working with
entrepreneurs and i do coach a lot of
entrepreneurs around this
subject and that's that that tends to be
what i focus on
but the dynamics and the beliefs that a
lot of guys have that are that are very
successful entrepreneurs that are that
are literally weapons in their business
life
but also subscribe to the you know happy
wife happy life notion or
you know they hear something cool like
oh polyamory so i can go bang other
people and everything will be fine but
then they realize when
their wife is getting you know smashed
by an nba basketball player they're like
it doesn't feel so good no yeah and
i know a lot of couples who have tried
polyamory tried
um poly relationships have tried open
relationships
most of them have failed um most of them
have blown up
and i think there is that it's either
okay we have to bring back the gray zone
a little bit or maybe it's not really
that worth it
um there's a really good book i think
you'd like it's called alphagod by
hacked by dr hector garcia
i don't know if you've heard of it but i
would i check it if you have some time
it's a really interesting listener
read he basically talks about um about
you know the very notion of
relationships and the type of
relationships over time but he more
specifically focuses on like the
the the super high value alpha that runs
harems
yeah like i i don't like i'm going to
all listen to it
and i'm going to get the rational mail
which you mentioned to me again i'm
gonna actually get the audio and just
kind of devour that because i need to
get into that again too
my my zone that i'm playing in is
certainly a
more contained container which is
yeah i i'm not looking to have two or
three partners [ __ ] i can barely manage
having one like i
i actually want to spend time with my
guy friends i want to spend time with
myself like
even last night my two boys were like
hey they're 19
and 17 are like hey do you want to watch
a movie i'm like yeah by myself and
they're like
no why can't we watch them together to
actually just want to i can lie in my
room
by myself with the tv and just stare at
it and not have to deal with anybody
for no reason other than i just wanted
some alone time yeah i don't i don't
need to have a polyamorous
like mormon relationship with three
wives running around my house a hard
pass i'm good
no that looks like a nightmare i've
watched a couple episodes of these guys
with these five wives and it's like oh
dude you really have just ruined your
life i've got i have a close friend of
mine who lives in eden utah and he owns
a former
um holly mormon home he's got five
kitchens in his home
and there's five distinct areas i'm like
dude hard [ __ ] pass like
no i'm good thank you massive pass
you